oh oh you all know who my match is who I
would date in a heartbeat
go ahead and tell them Evangeline how do
you show someone that you love them
tease them give them gifts
do you anticipate their needs do you
cook for them tell them or act awkward I
anticipate their needs I am gonna go for
cook for them because I think food is
the way to the heart you tell them you
tell them got it if I anticipated their
needs I'd be okay showing a lot anyway
on that I would tell them I love you
pick a color scheme the purple Pat Paul
mm-hmm I'm gonna go with green I'm gonna
go man I know who I'm gonna get I just
picked a rad yellow I think I would date
a different Avenger everyday if it was
based on the color ah to date a
different Avenger I wouldn't just
something
okay justice is simple complex pointless
a lie a goal a long game a goal complex
complex a long game how do you resolve
conflict Michael you talk it out make a
joke
do you wage emotional warfare sulk
silent treatment or apologize alone talk
it out
talk it out I kind of let you sulk -
he'd talk it out okay and I'm gonna say
so what's your treasure I gotta answer
oh no I know you said talk it out you
were agreeing with me you can change it
can you go back oh okay oh thank god
almost a travesty uh talk it out I'm
gonna pick talk it out what's your
tragic flaw and you kind of mean I care
too much i brewed a lot I'm insecure you
don't care enough or you have a bad
temper I care too much I think I've been
known to have a bit of a temper at times
so I'll go to that one I don't care
enough I think I'm kind
how do you defeat your enemies snarky
one-liners oh cool gadgets mental games
magic diplomat see brute strength that's
gotta be you diplomacy
I'll do Americans say diplomacy they do
that's okay it all just depends on the
advertisement and what part of Canada
you're from it's a different project
every single time I'm sorry we'll talk
about it tomorrow I'm gonna straight of
course you are the ghost I'm a ghost
snarky one-liners diplomacy what about
you how do you feel yeah I think so what
kind of kiss is the most romantic the
one with Paul Rudd Oh God [ __ ] you
Evangeline I kiss on the lips a kiss on
the neck I kiss on the wrist hot heavy
makeout session kiss on each finger
that's just I mean it's gotta be the
toes right kiss on the cheek kiss on the
hand kiss on the nose that's pretty cute
a surprise kiss maybe a kiss on the neck
mmm kiss on the next I'm gonna say a
surprise kiss
I think surprise kiss oh oh you all know
who my match is
who I would date in a heartbeat go ahead
and tell them Evangeline dr. strange dr.
strange okay you got black panther I'm
kind of your black panther
the best what's the perfect fit for a
wasp you might think no it's even
deadlier a black widow
you got Scarlet Witch much like much
like Wanda you're a low-key goth who
secretly longs for true love you're
capable and cunning and you're always
one step ahead of the game which is why
you and Natasha would make a smashing
pair I think it's really just a really
cool hair like flat pasta you find
someone you love and devote yourself to
them entirely you're usually the
smartest person in the room so you need
someone who can challenge you
intellectually
could you imagine the hot and heavy
verbal sparring oh the benedict
cumberbatch and I would get into a talk
about a romantic evening we're looking
for a sequel with you with Wanda I think
so and I mean the black like panther
maybe all of us together all of us
together where would Avengers go on
dates movies